rachel's in grand rapids hi rachel
welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi dave thanks for having me on sure
what's up
so i just graduated this year back in
april congratulations what's your degree
in
thank you i got my bachelor of fine arts
degree and i went for graphic design
which is something i've always really
wanted to do so i was proud of myself
that i did that
um but because going through college my
mom never really
prepared me for the effects of loans
um she always just kind of told me not
to worry about it
um so i graduated with like 58 000 worth
of debt
so i have been working a part-time job
for
a while now making like ten dollars an
hour and i just got my first full-time
job
yay so yeah i'm i know i'll be making
like 42
a year before taxes so i think it's a
good start but like
i am like absolutely terrified i don't
know what to do
about my loans when i'm obviously making
less a year than i have
in debt so um yeah i'm just kind of kind
of nervous going forward once i have to
start paying back
rachael what do you mean what are you
using your graphic design
um degree in because if you're making
ten dollars an hour no she's like
42 in her new job yeah that's what i'm
saying but yeah i just got it
you just got it so what i'm saying on
the side are you doing any graphic
design work on the side
i have i was actually thinking about it
before i got
the current job offer um i thought about
like starting an llc
and like kind of freelancing on the side
because i thought i mean i wasn't making
enough money on my old job
to even support myself so yes i thought
about it for
a while and then i got the job offer and
i was like i kind of took a breather
because i felt like a sigh of relief but
i don't know maybe i need to 42 is good
62 is better exactly so let's do 42 and
then unless you don't need an llc
you can just start freelancing yes all
you do is just it's a sole
proprietorship you just do it in your
name
they can just pay you on the side as
long as you're not doing anything in
competition with your existing employer
your main you don't want to do anything
unethical but if you can pick up some
freelance gigs on the side and make
another 20.
the great news about doing freelance
graphic arts is you can do it on your
schedule
and so you can work as much or as little
as you want and you want to work a lot
yes yeah because the faster you the more
you work the more money you make and the
more money you make the faster this debt
goes away let's do it with some math you
said 53 right
i have 58. 58. i'm sorry okay so
30 a year for two years and it's gone
yep okay you could do that on 62. you
can't do that on 42.
right 20 a year for three years and it's
gone
you can do that on 42 with no life yeah
but rachel i'm telling you right now
with you being young in this influencer
world
right now i believe you can honestly do
in between 25 and 30 000
a year on the side with your graphic
work you're gonna have to be real
aggressive
and let them know hey i'm here to help
you i can help design logos i can help
do this
but you really can i want you to stay on
the line when we get done
i'm going to send you a copy of my book
destroy your student loan debt it's
going to walk you through the process
on how to really aggressively go after
that but the key thing for you
is to make your shovel bigger and i
think you have a gold opportunity
because especially with your age going
towards that 30 and 40 year old tell
them hey i can help you
you can make some good money on the side
so stay on the line are you are you
willing
to live like a broke college student for
two years
i've basically been living are you
willing to live like that for two more
years
yeah i mean definitely if you'll do that
anthony can show you how to get out of
debt in two years there you go you
increase your income and you live on
nothing
yep and you can do this hold on we'll
help you out kiddo proud of you well
done